und jetzt steht da auf unrecht sehen sie
es karl lauterbach der
gesundheitsminister der als
bundestagsabgeordneter hier spricht
jetzt auch das bild ruhig mal groß das
wollen wir sehen was sie gerade im
deutschen bundestag abspielt also er
jetzt zum ende dieser impfpflicht
debatte impfpflicht ja oder nein er sagt
ganz klar ja und jetzt gegründet er noch
mal warum damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich möchte mich zunächst einmal für die
hervorragende debatte bedanken von der
ich sehr profitiert habe viel
mitgenommen habe ich hatte schon oft
gesagt an dieser stelle dass es hier
keine gelegenheit für parteipolitik und
von sehr wenigen ausnahmen verträgen
haben wir die gelegenheit heute genutzt
und dafür möchte ich mich ganz herzlich
bedanken
ich wünsche auch darauf hinweisen
winehouse arbeitet allen anträgen zu
unterstützen logistik mit rechtlicher
rechtlicher hinsicht medizinischer
hinsicht auch die anträge die mir
persönlich nicht gefallen werden
unterstützt das geht auch ausdrücklich
für anträge die vielleicht noch aus den
reihen der union kommen werden alles
wird gleichermaßen unterstützen und
dafür stehe ich zur verfügung an
wir kämpfen derzeit mit einer neuen
variante mit der omicron variante und
die omikron variante befällt auch
geimpfte und verläuft leichter
vielleicht ist das die alternative zur
impfung vielleicht brauchen wir die
impfpflicht gar nicht mehr vielleicht
ist die omikron variante der weg aus der
pandemie haus in die nlb ohne dass wir
die impfpflicht nötig hätten das ist
leider nicht so zum einen ist es jetzt
bereit so dass die modelle des robert
koch instituts zeigen dass diejenigen
die nicht geimpft sind von der omicron
variante bedroht sind und wir
wahrscheinlich mit also
belegungen der intensivstationen von bis
zu 5000 menschen rechnen müssen zum
zweiten gibt es so gut wie keinen
wissenschaftler international der mir
bekannt wäre der sagt die only variante
wäre die letzte variante mit der wir zu
rechnen haben und zum dritten ist es
auch noch so dass wir varianten erwarten
müssen die sowohl die sg
mutationen der komik und variante
enthalten wie auch die fitness varianten
anteile der tag der data variante somit
dass wir sozusagen die ansteckung der
omicron variante bekommen könnten und
den schweren verlauf der täter wehrte
diese sogenannten re kombinierten
varianten von diesen waren haben wir
angst und wenn wir dies im herbst sicher
vermeiden wollen sicher vermeiden wollen
dann ist der einzige weg eine
impfpflicht mit der wir uns alle
gegenseitig schützen und damit müssen
wir jetzt beginnen
ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen wir kommen
nicht weiter indem wir das problem für
uns weg schieben der kollege krings hat
ebene sagt in einer rede die teile hatte
die ich teile anderer nicht aber hatte
sagte wir können das doch erstmal
abwarten wir müssen so etwas wie einen
vorratsbeschluss haben das ist
medizinisch nicht machbar wir brauchen
für die umsetzung der impfpflicht
brauchen wir mindestens fünf bis sechs
monate das haus wurde die impfpflicht
jetzt beschließen und dann umsetzen dann
sind wir im herbst gerüstet wenn wir das
problem vor uns weg schieben dann wirkt
das problem in voller stärke
zurückkommen das können wir den kindern
den pflegekräften in ersten den menschen
die gefährdet sind die wir nicht impfen
können das können wir diesen gefährdeten
und belasteten menschen nicht weiter
zumuten wir müssen handeln und
ich höre auch immer wieder
fälschlicherweise
immer wieder fällt sich aber durch die
impfpflicht stünde im wege der fragt der
freiheit die stunde der freiheit
entgegen ich sage so viel die freiheit
gewinnen wir durch die impfung zurück es
ist das virus was uns belagert hegel hat
einmal gesagt und hat in dieser hinsicht
recht wie freiheit ist die einsicht in
die notwendigkeit und das ist der punkt
an dem wir dass wir wären nicht
zurückkommen zu dem leben was mir
geliebt und geschätzt haben ohne dass
wir jetzt den spaten drehen ohne dass
wir uns gemeinsam entstand und die
dreifache impfung ist der sichere weg
diese freiheit zurück zu erlangen
dass also die überzeugung des
bundesgesundheitsministers und
bundestagsabgeordneten der spd karl
lauterbach der sagt wir werden nicht zu
unserem normalen leben zurückfinden
zurückkehren ohne eine solche allgemeine
impfpflicht das sind starke und sehr
umstrittene worte von karl lauterbach
zum ende einer sehr spannenden sehr
emotionalen diskussion über die
impfpflicht ja oder nein hier bei bild
und im deutschen bundestag heute